[Música]
ya lo decía es el momento de la economía
por ello me acompaña en el estudio mí
con mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido vamos a iniciar hablando del
precio del petróleo que hoy mostró una
caída significativa así valentina y esto
sobre todo por los temores a una
recesión global que significaría en una
reducción significativa de la demanda el
petróleo se desplomó cerca de un 9 por
ciento en su mayor caída diaria desde
marzo el barril de petróleo brent para
entrega en septiembre cayó un 10 por
ciento en el mercado de futuros de
londres y rondó los 102 dólares por
primera vez es de mayo mientras que el
crudo estadounidense west texas terminó
un 8,2 por ciento menos eso significa
unos casi nueve dólares menos ubicándose
a 99 dólares el barril la inquietud
sobre la caída del consumo peso más que
las preocupaciones previas sobre el
suministro incluso en medio de una
huelga de los trabajadores del sector de
la explotación petrolera y del gas en
noruega que podría reducirlo lo futuro
del petróleo cayeron junto con el gas
natural la gasolina y las acciones
globales bueno y otro que mostró una
caída considerable
y el euro frente al dólar es todo sobre
todo por una creciente demanda del dólar
que es considerado un activo de refugio
sobre todo durante las crisis económicas
el euro se desplomó a mínimos de dos
décadas también por un aumento de los
precios del gas en europa a inicios del
día el índice del dólar subió un 1,6 por
ciento del euro cayó hasta un 1 75 por
ciento hasta alcanzar mínimos que no se
habían visto desde finales del año 2012
esta fue la mayor caída diaria para el
euro y la mayor ganancia de un día para
el dólar desde el año 2020 cuando la
pandemia azotaba los mercados bursátiles
en los cinco días que va de julio el
euro acumula una pérdida de más del 2
por ciento luego de otra similar en
junio la presión sobre la divisa fue por
los datos económicos que apuntan a un
creciente riesgo de recesión en la
eurozona la economía se ralentizó
bruscamente en junio en el sector
privado según 'samp' y global la
incertidumbre de la guerra en ucrania y
los problemas con el suministro de gas
ruso generan presiones sobre la divisa
europea 'jorge hablemos de donde vienen
estos temores de recesión en eeuu
las recientes proyecciones de bloomberg
economics muestran que ese riesgo es de
casi 1 de 3 las posibilidades de una
recesión es del 38% según un modelo de
probabilidad que utiliza bloomberg que
contempla datos como la construcción de
viviendas y encuestas de consumo
valentina hace apenas unos meses esa
probabilidad era de cero la preocupación
de los mercados sobre una recesión están
vinculadas también al endurecimiento de
la política monetaria de la reserva
federal de eeuu la fed lucha por
controlar la inflación más alta en 40
años pero lo hace subiendo los tipos de
interés que se traduce en mayor costo
del dinero y menos acceso al crédito el
temor de la recesión se atribuye a menos
ingresos para las empresas y un
deterioro en la confianza de los
consumidores también la institución
financiera japonesa nomura dijo que la
recesión en la eurozona llegará luego
del verano y que en eeuu ahora una
recesión algo más moderada que en otras
economías pero que tendría una duración
de cinco trimestres consecutivos o sea
más duradera bueno datos nada favorables
pero bueno a propósito del gas natural
se presentó el primer crucero construido
en francia que funcionara
natural liquado así es el barco será
entregado a mediados de octubre al
armador italiano suizo msc cruceros por
las instalaciones de sant hieren francia
las emisiones del co2 del c02 del barco
serán las más bajas del sector según la
compañía el barco de gas natural se
convertirá en el crucero de ese
combustible más grande del mundo y
completó con éxito su primera serie de
pruebas en el mar que incluían la
comprobación de los motores del barco la
maniobrabilidad el consumo de los
sistemas de seguridad y velocidad y
también las distancias de frenado el
barco se unirá a la flota oficialmente
en junio del año 2023 bueno ya no falta
casi nada para esta fecha vamos con los
indicadores económicos de esta jornada
empezamos con wall street que cerró en
territorio mixto debido a las
preocupaciones de los inversores sobre
esta posible recesión en eeuu que
comentábamos anteriormente en europa las
acciones cayeron un 2,1 por ciento ya
que la subida de los precios de la
energía a vigo los temores sobre la
inflación en américa latina la bolsa
mexicana de valores retrocedió un 1,11
por ciento en su principal indicador
atrás caídas para dos de las emisoras
más grandes del mercado local como son
defensa y grupo méxico estas muchas
gracias por esta ampliación económica ya
continuamos aquí en directo